you got it after you catch her gently
lower her to the ground okay
[Music]
hi I'm faith and today I'm going to be
going on a date with two people I've
never met before one person looks who I
can see but they're only allowed to say
what the other person personality wants
them back Daniel I am running the show
here
I'm really comfortable with the way that
I look I'm not the best
conversationalist you know I can be
pretty awkward at times so I think you
know having somebody can kind of
lines is probably going to help keep
things going smoothly I identify as
personality not because I don't think
I'm super hot but my personality is a
lot and if you can't like it and get to
know it then it's not going to work out
at the end of the day I'm gonna have to
choose who I like more lips or
personality I'm ready to go on this date
hi what's up hey how's it going I'm safe
hi I'm personality hi I'm personality
uh Daniel you do need to ask her to
stand up oh no could you actually do me
a favor and stand up for a second okay
right here is good yeah now pull out her
chair and offer it to her that's
peace
my mother raised me to be a lady my
mother raised me to be a lady to be a
lady yeah yeah okay how are you today
doing pretty good pretty good better now
that I'm here
question one what makes you unique I'm a
very creative person well I'm a very
creative person an artist since a young
artist since a young age I'm actually a
Dancer too wait really yeah that's legit
I've never met a dancer before like a
professional dancer what do you like to
do in your free time what do you like to
do in your free time I have a rabbit
and I know it's not like a dog or a cat
but I love you have a rabbit too I wish
Daniel I am running the show here
sorry you'll be second to my rabbit
because I love her so much she's a
loftier rabbit so she has like the long
ears oh that's so cute I'm like DIY like
little toys and stuff I'm gonna cry I go
to Petco yeah oh my God
I have a cat named Hazel I have a cat
named Hazel she's kind of a [ __ ]
we got water
take
it yeah actually and can I pour you some
more as well not only could I actually
pour you some more of you oh thank you
poor hormones
great keep going
keep going
keep going
keep going
keep going
oh my God
take the rose and tuck it behind your
ear
thank you wow not backwards
any weird childhood I don't know I was
homeschooled my entire life schooled my
entire life I grew up kind of close to
Amish Country Pennsylvania and my
roommates still to this day you know
mocked me for churning butter I'm not
I'm not Amish though okay what does
churning butter look like
um is it like in a pot it's in a barrel
it's in a barrel the air that you're
pushing in uh forces the cream to turn
into butter God it's getting very
scientific
[Music]
this is like very like wait how do we
are you shaking it
over shaking I guess they're holding
your hands are very cold
yeah
I got bad circulation I'm sorry it's
getting really romantic in there
actually do you want to stare at each
other's eyes for three minutes
yeah like totally candidly good for them
glad I'm not in there
[Music]
I think I can tell a difference between
looks and personality and little
differences that I'm picking up on and
I'm also hearing a slight buzzing in
your ear how could that be coming from
this cheater
thank you
I mean what do you want out of a
relationship I think I'm looking for
something I think I'm looking for
something that's like short-term now but
could turn into long-term and I travel a
lot for work what's your favorite place
that you've been I just did a tour and I
went to Memphis Tennessee that was super
fun
you should you should go well maybe
we'll go together exactly exactly ask if
she wants to have kids this is
so just
out of left field bit but okay do you
imagine or do you see yourself having
kids
oh
that's with me
[Music]
there's a voice in your head I would
maybe like to adopt for babies for
babies would be great have you ever
cheated in a relationship or been
cheated on
no to both and I mean I will say
cheating has definitely a deal breaker
for me oh yeah are you monogamous
cool I mean I have never cheated or been
cheated on also well
well I didn't cheat but they were dating
dating two people at the same time offer
her your hand and then look into her
eyes and say I would never do that to
you
I
would
thank you I appreciate that
take your hand back
foreign
okay all right you got it after you
catch her gently lower her to the ground
okay
oh this is
[Music]
once you help her up curtsy
I yes I don't know if I could do the
same for you but I appreciate it
this is so awkward to do with you right
here so I'll go look over here
okay I like what's in door a
I think I would like to meet personality
but I I I do like like I thank you
use it and not in like I'm hearing is
like one it was nice yeah
[Music]
girl no
foreign